two more mm-hmm you gave Final Fantasy
seven a ten out of ten which is
essential on the GameSpot scale it is
the first ten you've given and it is
white GameSpot's a seven seventy I don't
eighteenth something that wait no cuz I
think disco was 16 and then yeah 18 yeah
anyways do you want to sum up your
review just for background like overall
what you thought of it what like this
game you feel is essentially as quickly
as possible I'll give you a sentence
that review was I know I've said this
multiple times but like that was one of
the hottest things I've ever read I love
reasons you're at your final line like I
think really like it feels profound that
you say in the end of there's a lot of
people a lot of in comments to notice
that - I've been trying not to read the
comments cuz I'm terrified of words no
they're super very good sorry it's
surprisingly positive at least for you -
I don't know about GameSpot people
always find something to complain about
in games for a comment so yeah I mean
like it's it was a difficult game to
talk about but I can serve I could say
that I I loved it enough to give it and
and like there's something I've been
thinking about what is about it that
made me push it because the obviously
all know that I also love Sakura and I
reviewed that last year and I give her a
nine
and I was like looking at Final Fantasy
and I was like why why did I give this a
10 I can still have a nine what was it
about yet and I think part of it is the
nostalgia and to ignore the nostalgia
would be stupid like I don't think you
can do that it would be I think you'd be
failing at your job if you ignored the
nostalgia part of it and acting like it
didn't have an impact on you so I put a
bit in my review where I said oh yeah it
works as it no store does what no stuff
what it does to you but it's important
to know is that like it does more than
that and I think Shawn Lucas a testament
of this and same for a bunch of other
people if you listen to any other
podcast like the kind of funny guys Greg
Miller was talking about it same for
blessing I believe Andy Cortes
a bunch of people who have never played
the Final Fantasy 7 original and I just
like this is unreal and I think the
reason I deserves a 10 is it executes on
exactly what I wanted to be but but is
why I wanted to be wasn't just a remake
it was like taking something that was
beloved and remaking it in a way that is
better than the original very few things
can do that we've had amazing remakes
over the years Shadow of the Colossus
remake is fantastic as various other
remakes are good but nothing that took
the original source material and
reworked it into something as good as
this people are listening to this who
are like inclined to complain are gonna
complain about things that are changed
in the story
and yeah it does change things in a
story and it sets up things that to be
very different in the future going on
and like the problem I have with that
mentality is like like I see a lot of
people saying how can you give it a 10
when they did X Y & Z to this to this
thing and changed it and my thinking is
like but it doesn't right now I can't I
can't ding it for something that it
hasn't done what the game is is just
outstanding it's phenomenal it's this
beloved story told in a way that feels
modern and more human and more relatable
and more like just heartfelt it's it's a
level of of like nuance and writing that
I just did not expect from I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be honest I didn't expect it
from Square Enix I didn't expect it from
Final Fantasy I know I shouldn't say
that because because because if exists
and Civ is but is ever still like the
exception it was the exception it was
the one Final Fantasy game where if I
was here he'd be going mad but like that
is the strongest ruin for a fancy game
that exists but again like the mainline
Final Fantasy games are created by a
different team they don't have the same
writer and the writing quality on those
is subpar for me like it's not good it's
it's archetypes and they create
interesting worlds but there's things
about those games that I just don't ever
hit for me like the dialogue is off
often miss from
but in this game every part of it is it
feels like it lands and it feels like it
was really carefully thought thought of
and executed on like there's so many
funny moments so many lines of dialogue
that are endearing heartwarming get as
the odd clunker but it doesn't detract
from the experience
there are moments like where I thought
this does this is a level of poignancy I
never thought I'd get from Final Fantasy
there's lines where like the comedic
timing on is just perfect like there's
this and it's not just it's written as a
well good joke it's written well it's
delivered perfectly and then the camera
angle the directing behind it absolutely
nails it there's one line in particular
which I won't spoil which is like a
character is dressed in a way that no
one else expects and he's very much
aware of the fact that everyone else is
like why why you dressed like that and
the delivery of his line which responds
to kind of like the incoming barrage of
questions about the situation it's just
if flawless like I remember thinking
that is that is like high-level comedy
standard delivery and it's coming from
final fantasy which I didn't expect
but like it's an incredibly nuanced
story it deals with you know an
eco-terrorist group and it doesn't shy
away from the fact that some people
don't believe in their cause and for a
lot of the time the things that they're
trying to achieve are hurting the people
around them and although sure in the
future it may pay dividends so there's a
small chance that it might improve
things you're constantly being reminded
that this is a small group of people
fighting a behemoth and is there really
worth in sacrificing so much for the
small chance that you might change
something the people around you are
constantly reminding you of that the
characters that are involved in that
story are also reminding of you of that
Tifa
for example I mentioned in the review is
like she's constantly second-guessing
herself and she's second-guessing the
cause she's and she's doing it not just
because as a scripted thing she's
looking they show what what she's
thinking about they show a character
called Marlene who's a little girl who
works in the bar that she works at and
is like the main character one the main
character
it's Dora and like you can see that some
of her concerns are because of what she
feels for Marlene and what if she feels
for the people around her and it's such
a nuanced way to think about it and that
kind of stuff is is just it it's
considered and it fleshes those
characters out in a way that the
original just wasn't at all and then
there's like stuff like the combat which
I describe like as the perfect balance
between action from like the 15 error
and like lining returns and all those
kind of the lightening series and the
classic Final Fantasy 7 where you're
just standing in one spot and issuing
commands there's like a perfect but it's
the first time I described it as in my
review that the action focus doesn't
come at the expense of this strategy it
just feels so good and they kept the
materia system and they made it work
well the material system is probably my
favorite RPG upgrading system because if
four people don't know like you get this
gem which essentially encapsulates some
magic or Billy and then you use it and
it levels up and then you can take that
gem and give it to any character and
it's not like that character is not not
proficient in it because the experience
that you've pumped into the gem and that
magic it carries over so you can just
turn your like melee fighter into a
long-range magician if you want to and
it just works so good it's so freeform
you can come out whenever you hit a
roadblock with a character or a boss or
something like that you can just think
about how can I make this interesting
and make it more kind of fun for me to
mess around with the loadouts and see if
I can figure out and avoid Karma
that is fun the music is unreal oh it is
oh my god this is this I have thought
about the the soundtrack is $1 and I
constantly think about buying it and
like occasion to buy that yeah I was
picturing or repair and put on kazar
it'll be fine I was I was very very
happy that I found a version of it of
the soundtrack that I've been taking
from the demo on YouTube because when I
was writing it I like to try and get
into the mindset of the game I'm playing
and I had that playing in the background
and
okay it made me it makes you emotional
it make me it made me emotional right
like I was able to try and the one thing
I've struggled with was properly
representing my feelings about the game
but also making sure that I'm doing
justice to the fans that love Final
Fantasy 7 I wanted to make sure that
like my fandom was obvious to them so so
that they could look at me and my review
as someone they can trust but doing it
in a way that doesn't push it into the
territory where people think that I'm
not considering the things I'm saying
because I'm so blinded by my love of it
and that balance is really difficult to
strike and like I had that music playing
and there were moments where I'd like
just listen to the music to try and find
the words I wanted to say and that that
orchestral soundtrack is so evocative is
so well done the motifs that it carries
through like that then they they're so
subtle at times but then they build the
crescendos and whether it's like
Sephiroth's theme or Aris theme or just
like a random theme that is playing
while you're wandering like a sewer
district it's just it makes you listen
it's on I don't want to say it's on par
with persona 5 because persona 5 has a
very distinct style and pop and but like
in terms of quality and thoughtfulness
in production I think it's there it's
one of my favorite video game
soundtracks of all time and that is in
keeping with every other aspect of the
game visually it's absolutely stunning
it's one of the best looking games I've
seen and I don't put a lot of stock into
like how good a game looks and people
have been playing out all these low-res
textures in there but I honestly people
pointing that out are doing that at the
expense of everything else that looks
amazing
you're looking slow as textures and
everything okay but like in the thing
that blows my mind is like they're
looking at people looking at this door
which is like low blow poly or like this
flower and in the background is this
unbelievable varsity there's like this
this this massive plate above them in
the sky
is blocking out the Sun and the moment
you look at it it's just like you get
this feeling of oppression and feeling
of like being unable to escape the
misfortunes of living in the slums or
like you look at a character like Tifa
or Barrett and like you can see like
into their eyes and almost feel that
they're alive and like they the way
their hair moves the way they you know
just behave in movement and that all is
just lost and pushed aside because
there's a flower that's got not enough
polygons and I'm like you're missing the
point here it's just a gamer's yeah I'm
like I'm not I'm not trying to hate on
people like people care about things to
different levels but there's so much
beauty in this game it's overwhelming at
times
there's there's points where you're so
high up in this tower and you're looking
over Midgar and it will stop you in your
tracks because it's like you see in the
distance this horizon and there's a
desert Beyond and the light looks like
it's filtered through this this like
sand dunes and it's like covering the
city and you just look out there and
you're like this is unbelievable how
good this looks and it's just it's just
phenomenal to look at and I don't think
it's a as people say like all low-res
low-poly whatever it's just one of the
most stunning games I've ever seen and I
can't believe it's the kind of game it's
like it's how you'd imagine a game would
look this far into our Playstations
lifecycle it's done did you did you play
on a PlayStation 4 PlayStation 4 Pro
just out of curiosity I played on a pro
and that Pro was pulling in work like
there were times when I'm glad I had
that sound bar because I had to crank it
roll up to drown and drown up the ps4 as
fans but it will make your ps4 work but
that's just like one part of it that
it's the it's the characters that really
really really will stick with you and
like they I said in my review but this
is this is why people love these
characters like you can you love them
people love them back then but there was
a lot of like filling in the gaps
putting pouring your own ideas and
thoughts into these characters that had
been like created almost as character
shows but like they're very thin when
you look at them now
but you I dare anyone to spend some time
with Aerith and not just be like I love
her I love her so much and like just be
round Haifa and look at her and just be
in awe of how powerful she is what
should I just like destroy the world
around her with her punches and kicks
she's such a powerhouse and then she'll
come to you and have this moment of
vulnerability that oh just make your
heart sink and it's like having a close
friend to open up to you and like
Barrett you see him he's like I
described him as like a WWE pay-per-view
character because he's just screaming
and and he's always doing cutting a
promo but then you have a moment when he
just picks up his daughter and says
something to her and it will just melt
your heart and like wedge and Barrett
wedge and Biggs and Jesse and Jesse as a
character that is just given no time in
the original game and you meet her and
she's she throws herself a cloud she's
like maybe you'll be like you know my
leading man and she's like she is very
much horny on main like everyone
everyone is game but like there's a
moment where you do a question you
really request you do a mission
I hate describing of his missions and
quests because it just sucks the the
heart out of it you do you go on like
you do this job with her and you've
realized why she's like that she has
this she had a dream and it an impact
her did her personal in a specific way
and then you'd look at her completely
different from that point and you're
like oh I understand why you behave like
this you know it makes you think about
that case same for like pigs as well
like pigs is a character who like seems
like he's just very carries my egg like
cool calm collected soldier type and
then you there's a line someone says
where they're talking about someone else
in their past and they mention a name
and you're like oh wait a second you
connected to this connect to this
connect to this and you were here doing
this thing and you're like I did not
expect you to have a role in this thing
that's happening in front of me and like
even this there's a small thing that I
use to highlight why is essential to try
and do everything in that game there's
this mission where you go to is a part
of a city and a character which is a
teacher asks you to find a bunch of our
students that are running around the
city on patrol and
is you look at it and I even I remember
going great it's basically a dynamic
fetch quest and you can run around this
area and find these kids and I did it I
found these kids I returned them home
some of them like what trickier to find
because there's enemies that you fight
on the way and they're in the area and
then a few years a few missions later I
had to do a similar mission which was
like the same mission the kids are off
again or you need to go and find these
kids I was like what is this and then I
found those kids every single one of
those kids was wearing a wooden version
of clouds Buster Sword on their back
because they he had rescued them he had
become their hero and now they were
going around town just trying to be like
loud and that was like I could have
missed that easily but that little bit
of character development and you could
see the impact it has on cloud he's this
cold-hearted character he all only wants
money
but then he even he sees these kids who
idealize him and he's like damn I've
gotta pay attention to what's happening
and you can see him like he's thrust
into these relationships that he doesn't
want to start with and he just can't
escape him and it's he's caught on a web
of like humanity and that's the most
interesting part of this game and like I
said like there's a point where you meet
Arif
you walk through an area with her and
honestly like the music playing speaking
to her like I I couldn't contain my
emotions I was like I just burst out
crying cuz I was like this is everything
I wanted it to be and like that specific
moment speaking to eros it was like I
think it's one of the one of the Great
Smog M moments I've ever had so I just
love this game to to bits and it's
important to once again reiterate that
is enhanced by my nostalgia for the game
but I think if you if you even someone
like who has no nostalgia for it can see
the value in Grandia yeah Gianluca as
well it's never clicked for him before
and he was telling me like the same just
like how much he was really enjoying the
air I mean I almost like I'm more
interested to see what people think of
this game who are nostalgic because I
feel like nostalgia is tricky right
everyone's quick to say oh this is just
fueled by
nostalgia but if your nostalgia for
something and they like mess it up or
something isn't quite right like those
are the people that are gonna notice and
those are the people that is gonna call
it out it's not the people who are like
passing fans like myself like I'm not
gonna I'm gonna play this game I'm not
going to notice that kind of stuff
because I'm not nostalgic but I that
that's why like hearing the fact that
you're nostalgic and it's still it it is
more than what you'd expected and all
that stuff makes me even more excited to
play this game am more interested but I
guess just to kind of like move things
along here jean-luc you're someone who
didn't play the original Final Fantasy 7
right and you're still really enjoying
it - oh yeah yeah I never like a hundred
percent agree with everything tomorrow
said and I never played the original
Final Fantasy seven I have no nostalgia
for it I the few final fantasies I've
tried a bounced off of 13 I thought was
incredibly dull I 15 I like parts of it
and then got bored of it pretty quickly
this I was kind of I was expecting like
I was excited to try it but I was like
you know I'm not really sure how it's
gonna feel about it and I just kind of
wanted to know you know what this final
fantasy thing is all about because it is
that like one that everybody is so
nostalgic for and it is just it's so
it's so well done the characters are
like like in that first I played that
first hour I played like the demo which
is essentially the first chapter and I
remember being like yeah this is okay I
was kind of irritated to bear it and and
I was sort of like I don't know if this
is gonna if these characters are gonna
work for me but like it they if I if you
felt that way the same way I did I would
say like you have to give it more time
because like almost immediately I feel
like those characters start to like
expand and develop more and then like my
initial impressions of Barrett as like
you know tomorrow said he's just as very
loud boisterous person like melts away
when he interacts with his daughter and
even like his relationship with
cloud-like develops and it it's really
like interesting just like back and
forth between them I think the
the like way the story develops it it
was so interesting like because I was
the only one in the office who like
hadn't played the original who is
playing it who got it early and I just
assumed that all of the like story stuff
all of these like added layers of like
social commentary were in the original
and they they aren't like they're kind
of there but they're like people being
like oh yeah like that wasn't in there
and like you didn't they really didn't
like dive into like dealing with the
consequences of being you know part of
this like eco-terrorist group and like
the convictions of your choices and sort
of like the social hierarchy of this
like corporation who's kind of
oppressing this system like it's there
but it's apparently it's just not it was
it was kind of more surface level and I
was shocked because it felt so core to
the story it felt like like are you
kidding me like this this is what's
making this story for me and like I was
I was baffled that a lot of that stuff
was just not in the original like it
feels so necessary so quick quick
question for two more soon this is
obviously part one of three parts right
or multiple parts how no how long is
like like if you take this section how
long is a section in the original game
what about three hours
okay so okay that's where just thing
okay so there's a lot of as I say three
hours is probably an overestimation if
anything it might be like two been been
played has been playing it for the first
time recently he said it took him about
five ish okay so what he said to me it's
longer than I remember that but it's a
fraction of the story
yeah cuz how long is the game overall
like that when you're in Midgard
that's like lonely is wait did I get it
right yeah yeah yeah
fake final fantasy fan here like how
long is the game overall like once you
get out of there it's pretty long still
isn't like 80 hours the original yeah
yeah the original is like a minimum of
the problem with that game not problem
is the thing that game is like it's
called layers upon layers of buried
stuff so it can go for 100 do you want
to but like minimum just like 50 hours
50 60 hours if you're doing everything
you can inflame paths but like this game
is 40 hours based on a three hours for
three to five hours stretch of the
original and yeah pike and it doesn't
feel like they were just adding in
filler like you know it all feels
substantial it all feels yeah well it
all feels impactful it all feels
essential that's why I described it as
in my review like it doesn't it doesn't
make sense that this wasn't here it
doesn't make sense how this story could
have been told without this because it
seems so crucial to the tale yeah and it
just plays so good like like you said I
I've never I didn't like the combat and
15 like it it feels like they took a lot
of lessons from the way fifteen played
and really applied it to this one like I
think that combat like I've if they
finally like figured it out you know
like it feels like square has been like
trying to figure out how to like
modernize Final Fantasy combat for four
years and they've never quite hit it and
this feels like the first one where like
it feels good it's like just bouncing
back and forth between characters and
like queuing up the commands and like
when you figure out that system and you
like have all of your you know
character's abilities set in the materia
and you are like planning and
micromanaging your attacks and firing on
all cylinders like it's so satisfying
because you can the combats actually
like pretty tough like if you're not
doing a good job you can die really
easily but then when you like figure it
out and you nail it it is like so
satisfying yeah there's not there's no
like random in the originals Oh be like
you take three steps and you'll be in a
random battle and you're fighting like
constantly this is way more conservative
in the amount of fights you have and
because of that each fight is more in
depth and like more meaningful it's it's
they're trickier they feel closer to
something like you know a mini boss
every skirmish is a mini boss and then
there are bosses in between but yeah it
demands a lot of you but once you figure
it out it's it's this kind of
satisfaction that you have in playing a
Fire Emblem
XCOM that kind of strategic movement of
things and the satisfaction of watching
your plans pay off in the way that you
want in them and even that persona style
thing where
you identify a weakness and then you
exploit it and it puts that enemy on
their on their backs and then you
further jump in that kind of like the
stagger system is just like that where
you apply a pressure once you exploit a
weakness
it applies pressure to them and then if
you keep doing that they're staggered
and it leaves them completely open this
doesn't have an all-out cinematic attack
but it just means that you can pile on
the damage and it feels so good when you
do that because you feel smart and you
feel like you've you've kind of like
figured out a character or figured out
an enemy yeah in a way that like 15s
never did like I I just remember like 15
feeling a little like I'm just spamming
the button I'm kind of going through the
motions like it didn't quite click for
me that way know what Jake's going yeah
hope that happens camera's not Memphis
it's fine I'll turn it back on soon but
yeah like it's just like in 15 I just
remember that combat being like pretty
like I'm just kind of going through the
motions and hitting the buttons and this
I felt like I'm constantly thinking
about it and and even like 15s
open-world there are elements of it I
like but I think it was - it suffered
from just like it took forever to get
anywhere and a lot of times it felt like
filler like this feels I think the
restricted nature of the environments
really benefits the game it feels like
every area it feels handcrafted it feels
like like when you do the side missions
it's like these small little town areas
that that just feel big enough to feel
fun to roam around in but don't feel
like too big where you're just like
aimlessly wandering around in a way that
I I feel like about a lot of open world
games it it has huge Yakuza energy like
I you and me were both saying that like
both in the structure but then like you
mentioned that the humor is like it it
does I don't know if that's what they
did but it feels like they took some
lessons from like the way Yakuza fuses
like it's super serious tone with it's
like jokey like comedic moments and it
feels like they nailed that to me and
that's coming from like a Yakuza fan
first not a final fantasy fan like I
know the original game
also had its goofy moments but something
about the way they deliver it in this
one it works it doesn't feel like
irritating in the way that I've played
other JRPGs were like it's just like oh
this character is trying to be funny but
just comes off really obnoxious like
that doesn't happen in this game there
are parts in the original where the
goofier parts are actually in by modern
standards would be described as
problematic oh sure yeah those those are
in this remake but they are handled in
to know everyone's everyone's do
everyone's you know is different but I
would describe as progressive I would
describe it as smart I would describe it
as like very well done very well done
and unexpectedly like very very
respectful I there's a moment which
could have been a in the old game would
have been a lot of think pieces and
we're complaining in this game I felt
uplifted by it if I saw it I was like I
can't believe they said that and that is
exactly what a lot of people will be
wanting to hear is it is it what happy
to hear is it what the guy said after
the unexpected I so we got to move on
here but that I stuck with me as well
yeah but before before we do that I do
want to mention that next week you guys
are going to do a spoiler cast which
will go up in this podcast feed so make
sure to check that out and actually
before we move on Lucy I was curious if
you are planning on do you have
experience with Final Fantasy 7 are you
planning on playing this like I kind of
want to know your background because you
enjoyed Final Fantasy 15 right it did
but I didn't finish it because of
chapter 13 which so yes I never finished
it even though I know they patched it
I'm a big Kingdom Hearts fan for my sins
but I really enjoyed the demo for seven
hearing you guys talk about it reading
Tam's review listening to Greg and
talking to Greg about it I'm really
pumped to play remake and I was actually
like actually debating whether or not to
stop a Sona five this close to it but I
think persona is one of the games that I
can just do in the background
because I feel like I'll finish final
fantasy and if I time it right that's
when there's the new story stuff in
persona will be coming in so it's like a
nice little segue yes things I couldn't
play at the same time no I'm super
excited to play it and I have I have no
fan affiliation really with Final
Fantasy like I love 12 I've been to a
few the concerts I liked 15 didn't
really care for the other ones that I've
tried but I do want to play you know
eight and ten thirteen is the one I'm
referring to there
no no jazz to play fifteen I just apply
7 remake $0.50 ring sounds like you and
I are in the same boat except it's not a
I'm not a Kingdom Hearts fan and I you
love want to make sure everyone knows
that this is the game that Kingdom
Hearts wishes it was like okay yeah yeah
yeah
all right well I think that's a good
enough point to wrap up this Final
Fantasy 7 review discussion if you want
to hear more tune back in next week like
I said in this podcast feed John Luke is
going to be doing a spoiler cast so make
sure you finish the game obviously but
keep it out for that should be more good
discussion about the game but let's move
on to listener questions
[Music]